Y'all are always asking me about my outfits,
so today I'm going to be recreating four of my viral outfits
and telling you where I got each of the pieces from.
This is my most viral outfit of all time.
Every single time I post this outfit,
it goes majorly viral for some reason.
Just so funny. It's just a sweater from Ross
and a tiered skirt that I got from a modest clothing boutique.
The bow and the apron are just from Amazon.
This is one of my more recent viral outfits,
and this cracked me up because someone actually commented
and asked if I got the outfit from Spirit Halloween.
Actually, both of these pieces I found at TJ Maxx.
And the head scarf is just a cute
floral Bandana that I got from the scarf bar.
This blouse has served me so well with so many different outfits.
It is just perfect to wear with everything.
So I put it under this dress that I got at a local boutique.
This outfit also got a lot of hate.
The blouse is universal thread.
I thrifted it, but I think it's a target brand.
And then the jumper I got thrifted.
I also wore a head scarf with this.
And this scarf I thrifted as well.
Most of my clothes are thrifted.
Some of them are handmade.
And I just hope that this inspires you to go to the thrift store
or look at some Instagram thrift resellers.
And start putting pieces together
because some of my favorite blouses are just from like
TJ Maxx or Walmart or target.